traveling over 5 000 miles a prime
minister trying to get attention at home
his government announcing a refresh of
foreign and security policy costing 5
billion pounds but he's abroad going to
San Diego on the U.S West Coast to
explain why he's spending more on
defense
he's just one of the world leaders here
in California boasting about military
might because of threat not just from
Russia but China too it's clear that the
world has become more volatile the
threat to our security have increased
and that's why we're investing 5 billion
pounds more in our world-beating Armed
Forces over the next two years and
increasing our defense spending to 2.5
percent of GDP so we can continue to be
a world leader when it comes to defense
and keep our country safe
a massive and controversial deal set out
today to build and sell nuclear-powered
submarines to the Australians helping an
ally in the Pacific dealing with China
on their doorstep leaders wait years for
the kind of photo opportunity which
Richie sunak will experience later today
standing shoulder to shoulder next to
the U.S president talking about their
importance on the world stage
but there's no quick fix to Global
Security this is a poker game between
superpowers
a British prime minister with his
Australian counterpart Anthony albanazi
showing the depth of friendship between
the two countries and Alliance both men
want China to notice it's important day
for UK Australia relations with the
announcement that we're making a long
planned meeting about military security
abroad but the PM found himself trying
to shore up Economic Security at home as
well a bank collapse meant multiple
virtual meetings with his Chancellor a
PM finding plans change when a real
crisis hits Sam Coates Sky News San
Diego